se nos dice supongamos que a + b es = 2a
cuál de estas expresiones es equivalente
a b - a Sería bueno que lo intentaras
que que pusieras pausa al video y vieras
Bueno si puedes hacerlo intenta
averiguar cuál de estas expresiones es
equivalente a b - a y lo que tienes que
hacer es considerar simplemente algunas
manipulaciones algebraicas entonces
Bueno supongamos también que ya lo
hiciste Ahora hagámoslo juntos así que a
+ b es = 2a lo primero que yo haría es
poner todas las as de un solo lado y una
manera de hacer eso es bueno Yo podría
restar a de ambos lados Ajá entonces si
yo hago eso Si yo resto a de ambos lados
me queda solo B del lado izquierdo y del
lado derecho me quedará 2a - a lo cual
es igual a a ajá si yo tengo dos cosas
de algo y le resto uno entonces me queda
uno de ese algo mm entonces 2a - a = a y
queremos averiguar cuánto es B - a ahora
por suerte por suerte puedo averiguar
eso Si resto a de ambos lados entonces
voy a restar a de ambos lados y obtengo
del lado izquierdo B - A qué es lo que
queremos averiguar B - a es igual a a -
a que es igual a 0 entonces B - a es ig
a 0 pero como tú puedes ver esa no es
una de las opciones Entonces algo no
estamos considerando Ah veamos si
podemos averiguar algo algo más a partir
de lo que se nos da entonces dado que
esa no es una de las opciones veamos qué
más se puede hacer entonces B - a es = 0
pero esa no es una
opción habrá alguna otra manera de
manipular esto podría yo directamente
restar 2a de ambos lados si obtenemos
nuevamente que b - a es igual a 0
entonces Bueno ahí eso como que no es
correcto Ah bueno aquí de hecho Okay
esto es interesante Ya lo
vi era algo truculento muy bien Entonces
tenemos que b - a es = 0 eso es cierto
Sí B - a es = 0 Entonces si tomamos el
negativo de de ambos lados de esta
ecuación si multiplicamos ambos lados
por -1 entonces multiplicamos ambos
lados por -1 qué obtenemos del lado
izquierdo obtenemos a - b Y de lado
derecho seguimos obteniendo 0 Entonces
si B - a es = 0 el negativo de B - a es
a - b también es igual a
0 y aquí está la opción a - b así que
Bueno ese estuvo truculento pero estuvo
muy
divertido